uk health security agency is
investigating after polio was detected
in sewage from north and east london the
last case of wild polio contracted in
the uk was confirmed in 1984 and the uk
was declared polio free in
people are being urged to ensure that
their vaccines are up to date well let's
speak now to professor adam finn who's
head of pediatrics at the university of
bristol and a member of the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization or jcvi although i think
you're speaking in a personal capacity
today for us thanks so much for talking
to us what do you make of this discovery
of polio in sewage in london is it a
cause for concern do you think
yes i know it is it's something we do
need to pay close attention to this is
something that's happened in other
countries in the west uh in recent times
but not so far until now in the uk
uh it's not entirely surprising that
this has happened but it is something we
should be uh paying attention to and
doing our best to stamp out well yes and
could it come about because people have
had a vaccine against polio and that's
somehow been shed from their systems and
is being picked up in sewage
that is what's happened although not the
vaccines that we're using in the uk
because since 2004 we've been using an
injected inactivated vaccine that
doesn't contain any live virus but the
oral vaccine which does contain live
virus is still widely used in other
parts of the world as part of the polio
eradication program
and so the virus will have been imported
by someone coming from one of those
countries who's received the vaccine
there
so does it mean that it could just be
coming from people who are vaccinated
and there's no reason to suggest that
it's spread at all
i'm afraid there is reason to suggest it
spread because this has been picked up
now over a period of several months
and when we see importations that are
like a one-off if you like somebody's
come with that recently been vaccinated
that usually just
pops up for a short time and then
disappears whereas we're seeing
genetically related viruses persistently
over a period of months now
and that strongly suggests that there's
transmission going on between people
within the uk and in this area of london
in particular and how risky is that
because there is a widespread
vaccination program against polio in
this country isn't there
yes the risks are low because just a
very large majority of people have been
while you know have been vaccinated
adequately to protect them but
nevertheless there are people who
haven't been
vaccinated at all and others that have
not been fully vaccinated
and these kind of viruses
can actually cause polio even though
they come from the vaccine they can
gradually
evolve back towards virulence and cause
paralysis so this is something we do
need to pay attention to and in the
short term
people should check that their children
have had all their schedule vaccinations
particularly if they're in north london
but elsewhere as well just to minimize
any possible risk
and remind us what we're talking about
here with polio because we've not had
many cases of it for us for some time
remind us what kind of a disease this is
yeah i mean vaccines are a victim of
their own success aren't they we we
constantly forget about the diseases
that used to exist that have disappeared
as a result of vaccinations and polio is
a good example of that it causes a an
illness with fever a bit like flu
and most people who get it make a full
recovery without any serious problems
but unfortunately a minority of people
can get this paralysis usually affects
the legs but it can affect other parts
of the body
and in some cases it's permanent so that
you get weakness of one or other of the
limbs
people can't move normally and then even
though they recover from the infection
that can on some cases be a permanent
problem so it's a serious illness one
that we definitely want to avoid people
getting no absolutely and and are there
symptoms people need to look out for if
they're if they're not vaccinated and
are concerned
uh well the the general symptoms that
people get
are very easily muddled up with other
infections fevers um aches and pains um
headaches
flu-like symptoms but if you experience
any kind of weakness so that your
muscles don't seem to be working
properly and you can't seem to move
normally that's a sure sign uh that you
may have polio there are other causes of
those symptoms but polio is a possible
cause
and should certainly lead people to get
medical attention if they experience
anything like that okay but the real
advice today professor adam finn is uh
check the vaccination status of yourself
and your and your kids basically
absolutely children get three doses as
babies in the first year another dose
booster at three and then a final
booster at the age of around about 13 14
make sure they've had all of those doses
if not get in touch with your gp and get
them immunized up to date
professor adam finn thanks very much
indeed really interesting to talk to you
and thanks for filling us in on that we
appreciate it
thank you